exercise look man you know for hundreds
of thousands of millions of years and
stuff you've been like walking nine
miles a day and hunting saber-toothed
tigers and Mastodon and whatever the
[ __ ] else is out there that's how we
operated we didn't sit in like a
sedentary fashion in a chair as a couch
potato driving at a desk all day get
some [ __ ] exercise I shouldn't have
to explain it to you exercise move more
eat better uh pick up heavy [ __ ] put it
down you will have deep restful like I
always sleep better when I have busy
days if I've been riding my bike for two
or three hours if I was at the dojo for
90 minutes uh if I have a good workout
um all of these things will let you
sleep better big smash session you know
before bed all of these things will let
you sleep better uh get the exercise get
it daily move more eat better
another one which I don't do but I've
tried which can be helpful is hot baths
before but apparently hot like heating
up your body and then cooling it down
very quickly before you go to bed is
very helpful
um I have a hot tub and whenever I use
it before I go to bed like it's usually
dark you know I just kind of go go back
there flip it open and you know chill
out grab a tea you know sometimes it's
just me sometimes just me and the chick
we're just sort of chill out there but
but the hot tub is is usually set to
like 100 203
um you know you get out there it's hot I
get out it's cold as [ __ ] outside
obviously in the winter time and
um you know but by the time you dry off
and you get into bed you're like oh it's
just nice it just feel like your body
feels rested it's tired it just wants to
sleep uh heating up your body with
either a hot bath or a hot tub is always
a good idea before bed I don't do them
very often but I find them very
effective if and when I do do them uh
another really important tip here
for good sleep is your body isn't going
to be able to go into deep restful sleep
if if you have a full stomach
um I hate it like I hate eating dinner
at eight nine o'clock ten o'clock
um like even times if there's an event
or something happening and there's
dinner and dinner's at like eight nine
o'clock I I don't even usually eat like
a full meal like I'll eat dinner earlier
like I don't give a [ __ ] I'll just have
like a bunch of food or some snacks
around five or six o'clock and then when
the dinner comes for the event I'll just
maybe have a nappy or a drink or
something but I I don't like going to
bed with a full stomach it's
uncomfortable your digestive system uses
a lot of resources to move food digest
it and all that sort of stuff and you're
always going to get far far better sleep
I find personally if I stop eating after
about six o'clock that's the best
sometimes it's hard to do if you're just
chilling you're watching something you
know there's a good movie on and you got
Stacks going
um but my last meal of the day like my
dinner is usually five five thirty I
don't have late dinners I I tend to
avoid eating late and you'll always
sleep better if you have more of an
empty stomach or several hours have
passed since your last meal some people
say you know make sure it's at least
three or four hours for me it's usually
three and a half hours or so so that
seems to work pretty good
um
losing weight is pretty helpful if
you're fat I hate to tell you but you're
not going to get quality sleep it's
usually because your oxygen like you're
going to be oxygen deprived people that
are overweight obese often are deprived
of good quality sleep because of they're
not breathing properly they're snoring
they stop breathing in the middle of the
night
just not good so if you're overweight I
mean there's lots of perks of losing the
weight aside from like looking better
and you know women will be more
attractive to you obviously but you also
sleep better too so lose the damn weight
um
the other point that I have to that as
well is spo2 monitoring which is your
blood oxygen levels your blood oxygen
ideally should be like 98 99 like 98 is
great right
um they have these devices and I got
some of them queued up over here so
let's talk about that real quick since
we're on that topic
um
I've been using these for a few years I
I love them because you can't manage
what you're not measuring at the end of
the day you really can't you know like
how do you know if you're losing weight
if you're not you know stepping on a
scale how do you know if your blood if
your body composition isn't Improvement
if you don't have a body fat percentage
measurement how do you know if your
blood Labs you know if your blood is is
healthy and your organs are healthy if
you're not checking your Labs every you
know three to four months you're not
going to know you have to measure things
if you want to manage them and one of
the things that is a very useful and
inexpensive Tool uh you know to measure
sleep is sleep monitors
um I've used this company's product for
quite a few years now it's called looky
Tech
l-o-o-k-e-e tech.com so I just look it
up they're not paying me to say any of
this it's not an affiliate link or
anything although they should be paying
me because I'm going to sell a shitload
of these things for these guys I use
this one uh for several years it
unfortunately it only lasted about three
years and then it just stopped working
it it stopped collecting the data for
whatever a reason I don't know if the
battery died or there's something wrong
with a cord but I just ordered this one
the other day because it just died on me
so this one kind of eliminates the chord
situation they're about the same price
they're about 200 bucks and I think if
I'm not mistaken they have a Black
Friday sale on right now so a lot of
this stuff is on sale so I just bought
this one the other day
um and it essentially tracks your blood
oxygen levels do they have a picture
here on the screen of the app
um
no they don't have it here but they have
this app hang on it might be if I click
through over here
there it is but they have this app like
this and it'll show you your recording
time uh drops your average spo2 95 kind
of getting on the Lower Side
um ideally you want it around 98 97 like
I I like mine higher than 90 96 97 it
also tracks your lowest spo2 throughout
the night it's got these little bar
graphs that tracks everything attracts
your heart rate and it also tracks your
motion so if you're moving around a lot
in your sleep it tracks all those things
um it's a very very interesting tool and
it's it's comfortable to wear you don't
notice it that it's there it collects a
lot of data
using this was one of the reasons why I
went and got a sleep study done which
I'll talk about as well but I started a
note like like this one here for example
shows an average spo2 of 95. I started
to notice more orange on mine and in
some cases some red drops throughout the
night which was a strong indicator that
I wasn't breathe enough or that I wasn't
getting enough oxygen and that's a
problem
more plates more dates Derek has talked
about and I watched his channel you know
often you know as a tool and it's got
lots of resources
this talked about you know if you don't
have good quality sleep and if you have
sleep apnea you're you're going to
suffer at some point like like it's
going to catch up to you it's going to
knock years off your life a lot of guys
that are that are bodybuilders too so
not just fat dudes but if you're a
bodybuilder and you've got a big thick
neck right and that's kind of me like
I've got a bigger neck
um
it it makes it harder for you to breathe
properly at night
um so I tracked the data for several
months I noticed the spo2 wasn't great
it wasn't brutal but it wasn't great so
I had my doctor
um I don't know if they write a script
or whatever but they have to do like a
referral for a sleep study the sleep
studies here in Canada are free
um I don't know what it would cost
elsewhere in the world but you know
whatever it costs if if you're tracking
your blood oxygen and it's low or it's
not high enough or you see significant
dips another strong indicator worst
feeling ever
is if you're asleep and you're just like
they are asleep and this usually happens
when you're sleeping on your back
and then you wake up gra gasping for air
coughing like like just coughing that's
your body waking you the [ __ ] up because
you stop breathing for so long that your
heart and your brain is being deprived
of so much oxygen that it throws that
electrical signal to wake you up and it
shocks you away it is the most bizarre
and uncomfortable and rude awakening
that you can possibly have I've had it
happen to me a couple times in my life
it sucks it's a strong indicator that
you're not that you're not breathing
um so if that's happened to you I would
definitely recommend get us getting a
sleep monitor modern your blood oxygen
level and if it's called for get a sleep
study done to see what's actually going
on there
um so check out that product it's 200
bucks it's not expensive it works really
well the data that it collects is
totally valuable I would definitely get
it
um I see somebody here in the comments
says that it vibrates to if your blood
oxygen gets too low the problem with
that is I set it the lowest setting and
you'd feel it and then you wouldn't feel
it when you're asleep like the whole
idea of the vibrating is it's supposed
to vibrate on your finger to wake you up
to remind you that you're not getting
enough blood oxygen but the problem is
is if you're in a a deeper sleep and
it's vibrant you don't feel it after a
while like you build up a tolerance to
it and you literally don't feel it like
I've I've seen the charts in the morning
and it's going to be like oh it vibrated
there there there there there and there
and I didn't feel [ __ ] because I was in
such a deep sleep so the vibrating
function on it I'll be honest with you
it's not particularly useful
um it's fine if you're you know like
you're falling asleep and you're not in
the right position it's fine if you get
up in the middle of night take a piss or
something like that and you find that
you're not breathing properly when you
get back in bed you know before you fall
asleep you'll feel it then and you maybe
switch positions to get better uh flow
but like trust me you're you are just
going to sleep through it right like
you're not going to wait
you're not gonna be woken up by it if I
can put it that way hey guys I really
hope that you enjoyed that short clip if
you did consider supporting the creation
of content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational Essentials
for health immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out